now British Prime Minister Theresa May
has called on UK lawmakers to support
her European Union divorced deal two
days before a crunch vote in Parliament
she said failing to back her deal on
Tuesday would be catastrophic for the
country Britain is set to leave the EU
on the 29th of March but has yet to
finalise the departure terms on Saturday
lawmakers and ordinary people joined
forces on the streets of London to
protest Mays leadership and to call for
fresh elections well let's bring in DWS
London correspondent dear Kate Moss for
more periods as we know Theresa may have
postponed the last vote on the brexit
deal because she knew she was going to
lose that vote are her chances any
better this time around
well it seems that opinion have actually
hardened over Christmas and she
postponed that faith and brexit is
really everywhere just this morning in
my neighborhood there was a stall of
people who are making an opinion poll of
of passers-by as brexit going well and
there was one tick that brexit is going
well and which there were sort of
hundreds of of ticks that breaks it is
not going well and people were demanding
a change of action and this is being
mirrored also in the houses of
parliament
there are many MPs were trying to come
together actually a cross party and
trying to look for a different strategy
on brexit because nobody is happy or
very few employees seem to be happy with
two resumes deal as yet there is no
second deal or no alternative emerging
but this is definitely what a lot of MPs
are voting on and really doesn't look
very likely that the votes going to go
through on Tuesday all right bigoted so
you say opinions have hardened it's
likely she won't win this vote but if
she does lose is Theresa main going to
be out of a job well she herself hasn't
really said anything about a possible
plan B what's going to happen if she
does lose the vote even though for weeks
and weeks it looks like she's not going
to get through so we're really in
unchartered
it depends a little bit I think also on
by how much she loses if there's a huge
huge number of MP hundreds that would
put a lot of pressure on her on the
other hand she has always been extremely
resilient even her opponents have had to
admire her resilience and and the
steadfastness that she is going through
this process and really determined to
deliver brexit and what she thinks is
best for the country she has said that
she's not going to resign but we really
don't know there is of course the
possibility that the Labour Party will
ask for a vote of no-confidence but
they've also said that they are only
going to do it when they are sure
they're winning it so we really don't
know what's happening if she does lose
DWS beer get moths reporting from London
thank you